- No, no, no, no, no, no. Don't turn it over again, Jameis. Not again.
- HELLO, JAMEIS.
- I’m not supposed to talk to strangers, or the media, or my teammates—
- I’m Franchise, the dependable clown.
Would you like to join me-
Oh your decision-making just naturally puts you in the sewer?
OK, this was easy.
- Welcome to a meeting of the fluffing losers club.
- I haven’t seen you guys since our rookie year. Why now?
- The evil clown is back, and it’s going to terrorize.
Gridiron Heights with everyone’s worst fears!
- Wait, where’s Ben?
- BACK UP, BACKUPS!
- 🎶RUDOLPH THE BROWN-NOSING STARTER. 🎶
- [Evilly:] QUACK QUACK QUACK QUACK QUACK.
- Flipping CLOWN not gonna fudging get ME.
- We made a deal. Remember?
- YOU’LL NEVER DEFEAT ME, 2004 DRAFT CLASS.
-I’m fluffing Phil Rivers, and you don’t
froggin’ mess with New York!
- 🎶YOU CAN’T WIN THE AFC. 🎶
- Sorry, San Diego.
- Eli frogging stole my life!
- Chirp chirp. You’ll lose forever, Larry.
- No, 2004 is our last rebuild!
- I’ll be back!
- I don't get why they don't just run through each other.
- Don't question it. We're just a PlayStation ad.
- PlayStation 4, the best place to play.
- Can’t frickin’ believe we gotta save the GD day again.
- What’s this?
Oh no!
IT’S DANGEROUS TO RUN.
- MAKE THE STRANGE MAN GO AWAY.
- NO! Well, you know, maybe I could start…BUT NO.
- AHHH!!!
- Look, it’s not real!
- YOU’LL NEVER BE PHILLY SPECIAL!
- AHHHHHHHH!
- Hey there monster, what’s new with you?
- You don't get to play for two weeks.
-AHHHHHHHHH!
- YOU’RE MINE, MARIOTA.
- It’s not real.
- Um, I think that’s actually Ryan Tannehill.
- THIS WAY!
- OK, well Larry is clearly a Hall of Famer, right?
- Eli has the rings.
- But Phil’s consistency, my God!
- [All three:] AHHHH!
- 🎶You don’t inspire us! 🎶
- I’VE TRIED TO GIVE BACK TO THE GAME AS MUCH AS IT’S GIVEN TO ME!
- Everyone doggon loves you.
- That means a lot.
- YOU’LL THROW FLOATERS TOO.
- It’s me. Matt Shaub! Also 2004 draft class!
- Oh, yeah.
- AHHH!
- Oh my God!
- Don’t hurt me, Eli.
- I can’t...But he can.
- Hey, 2004 Eli,  F--K you.
- WOAH.
- I’m a Hall of Famer...to my friends.
- OK, SO, UH, OUR DRAFT CLASS WILL JUST STAY HERE?